>> Tucker: SOME THINGS JUST GO
WELL TOGETHER.
SALT AND PEPPER, PEANUT BUTTER
AND JELLY, FRENCH TOAST AND ROOM
SERVICE.
HILLARY CLINTON AND IGNORING
SERIOUS SEX ABUSE ALLEGATIONS.
IN THE 1990s HILLARY CLINTON
DEFENDED HER HUSBAND IN THE FACE
OF THEM.
IN THE 2,000 SHE WAS A CLOSE
CONFIDANT OF HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
HER HUSBAND MEANWHILE FLEW
AROUND ON JEFFREY EPSTEIN’S
PLANE.
IN 2018 HILLARY CLINTON PIVOTED
COMPLETELY AND BRETT KAVANAUGH
AS YOU REMEMBER WAS ACCUSED AND
HILLARY CLINTON SAID HIS ACCUSER
HAD TO BE BELIEVED.
>> LOOK.
I WATCHED AS MUCH OF HER
TESTIMONY AS I COULD DO.
I FOUND HER VERY CREDIBLE.
I FOUND HER WILLINGNESS TO SAY I
DON’T REMEMBER THIS BUT I
REMEMBER THAT TO BE VERY
CONVINCING.
>> Tucker: WELL, YOU KNOW
THINGS CHANGE.
AND HILLARY CLINTON HAS
REDISCOVERED THE VALUE OF
SKEPTICISM AND A DUE PROCESS.
WHY?
TWO WORDS, TARA REID.
THAT’S A FORMER BIDEN STAFFER
WHO ALLEGES THAT BIDEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED HER.
NO, NOT SEXUALLY HARASSED BUT
ASSAULTED PHYSICALLY.
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN’T JUST
ACCUSE UP THAT BUT SHE GUSHED
ABOUT BIDEN’S CHARACTER.
>> WE NEED A LEADER AND
PRESIDENT LIKE JOE BIDEN.
I ALSO KNOW ABOUT JOE THE
PERSON.
I’VE SEEN HIM UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL NOW FOR MANY YEARS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THE SAME VALUES
IN COMMON, IT’S A KIND OF
COMPASSION AND CARING THAT WE
NEED FROM OUR PRESIDENT AND
WHICH JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
EXEMPLIFYING THROUGHOUT HIS
ENTIRE LIFE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU WERE
PROBABLY TOO TRANSFIXED BY
HILLARY CLINTON TO NOTICE THE
GUY NEXT TO HER, JOE BIDEN I
THINK HE FELL ASLEEP A COUPLE OF
TIMES IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT.
HE’S PROBABLY STAYING UP LATE
RIGHT NOW FIGURING OUT HOW
SHAKEN SNATCH THE NOMINATION
FROM HIM.
JEANINE PIRRO JOINS US TONIGHT.
THIS IS ALMOST TOO EASY BUT I
HAVE TO GET REVIEW OF THIS.
AND NOW SHE THINKS WE SHOULD
PAUSE BEFORE JUDGING?
>> YOU KNOW, HILLARY CLINTON
ENDORSING JOE BIDEN WHEN HE’S
BEING ACCUSED OF, AS YOU SAY,
NOT SEXUAL HARASSMENT BUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT, IT’S LIKE THE
KISS OF DEATH.
THE WOMAN IS LITERALLY A
STANDARD-BEARER, OF
SEXUAL PREDATORS.
I WAS AN IMMEDIATE OUTCRY OF HER
LAUGHING ABOUT THE WHO A
12-YEAR-OLD INTO A COMA OR HER
EMAILS THAT WERE FOUND ON
ANTHONY WEINER’S LAPTOP OR
JEFFREY EPSTEIN WAS HANGING OUT
WITH WEINSTEIN WHEN EVERYONE IN
HOLLYWOOD KNEW WHAT WAS GOING
ON?
THIS WOMAN IS A WOMAN WHO DOES
NOT STAND FOR WOMEN.
FOR HER RIGHT NOW TO ENDORSE
JOE BIDEN IS REALLY TO IGNORE
WHAT ALL OF THE "ME, TO"
MOVEMENT SHOULD BE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT BRETT KAVANAUGH
AND TARA REID.
TARA REID ACCUSING JOE BIDEN,
AND I COME TO THIS TUCKER AS A
PROSECUTOR AND A JUDGE.
I STARTED A SEX CRIME UNIT IN
THE D.A.’S OFFICE AND I KNOW
THIS BUSINESS VERY WELL.
TARA REID MADE A NAME IMMEDIATE
OUTCRY OUTCRY.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT IT’S
ADMISSIBLE EVIDENCE AND THE JURY
IS ALLOWED TO FIND THE VICTIM
MORE CREDIBLE IF SHE MADE AN
OUTCRY.
TARA REID TO MEET AND OUTCRY TO
MOTHER, HER BROTHER, AND HER
NEIGHBOR WHO SUPPORTS JOE BIDEN
WHEN HE SAYS TARA REID DOESN’T
LIE.
TARA REID ALSO MADE AN A RECENT
OUTCRY TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
SENATE.
THIS HAPPENED TO HER WHEN SHE
WAS WORKING FOR JOE BIDEN AND
WHEN SHE MADE THE COMPLAINT TO
THREE PEOPLE ABOUT JOE BIDEN
PUSHING HER UP AGAINST THE WALL
IN THE SENATE WITH NO ONE ELSE
AROUND, PULLING UP HER SKIRT AND
PUTTING HIS -- I WILL GET
GRAPHIC BUT, SEXUALLY ABUSING
HER, THEY MOVED HER AWAY FROM
WHERE SHE HAD BEEN WORKING IN
THE SENATE OFFICE TO A ROOM WITH
NO WINDOWS AND ALL THREE INTERNS
AND ALL THREE CAN ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT SHE WAS ABRUPTLY TAKEN
AWAY AS THEIR SUPERVISOR.
FINALLY, WE HAVE DOCUMENTARY
EVIDENCE THAT SHE WORKED WITH
JOE BIDEN.
WE HAVE SENATE RECORDS, AND EVEN
THOUGH THE MOTHER PASSED,
COMPLAINED TO LARRY KING.
WE HAVE THAT EVIDENCE IN 1993
WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
NOW WHEN IT CAME TO CAVANAUGH KA
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD DID NOT
KNOW THE DATE, TIME, PLACE OR
YEAR.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS PEOPLE
THAT SHE SAID WERE WITH HER WHEN
BRETT KAVANAUGH ASSAULTED HER
SAID, NO WE WEREN’T.
THIS IS PURE UNADULTERATED
POLITICS, SUPPORTING PEOPLE WHO
YOU WANT TO BE EMPOWERED TO.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH WOMEN
AND PROTECTING WOMEN IN THE
SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: WHILE IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WOMEN, I AM
NOT MUCH OF A FEMINIST BUT I
WOULD NEVER HANG AROUND WITH